from calorie counts portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between m ms in the uk and the us this
is food wars
here in the us we have eight different
portion sizes of m ms all the way at the
end here the smallest portion is known
as the fun size this little guy is .6
ounces or 18 grams then single size bag
1.69 ounces then we go up to the box
this is 3.1 ounces or 87 grams now we
have the share size peanut makes its
first appearance this is 3.27 ounces or
92.7 grams well bigger of a pouch we
have the 10.7 ounce or 303 gram sharing
size pouch part two now we jump up to
the family size this is 19.2 ounces 545
grams throwing a party m m's got you
covered this is the party pack 38 ounces
1 105 grams and the biggest portion size
you can get is this the pantry size tub
62 ounces
1757 grams in the uk m m's come in four
standard portion sizes around the
holidays you can get a selection box
with a small packet of m ms that weighs
45 grams but unfortunately we couldn't
get one today our standard pouch is 125
grams then we move up to a more to share
bag which for standard chocolate m ms
comes with 250 grams the largest size
available in the uk is a party bag i
went to about eight different
supermarkets and i couldn't find one but
usually they would contain one kilogram
of m m's so we're gonna make our own
there is our unofficial party sized bag
one kilogram of m ms all said america's
largest size is 75.7 larger than the
uk's
in the uk the portion sizes also vary
slightly depending on which flavor of m
ms you've opted for a mortar share bag
of chocolate m m's is 250 grams but a
mortar share bag of crispy m ms is just
246 grams if you want the most value in
the uk opt for peanut m ms a mortar
share bag of those contains 268 grams
are the m ms themselves different sizes
in the uk in the us we're going to weigh
out 100 grams of chocolate m ms and
count them to see how many you get one
that's so annoying it was so close to
being 100 grams of exactly 100 m ms but
instead 100 grams of uk chocolate m ms
is 102 m ms 100 grams of american m ms
is 114
m m's
so what does that mean ours are smaller
how do we feel about that i know it's
better or worse but portion size don't
stop there you can also buy m ms
directly from the m m website the main
purpose of this seems to be catering for
large events like weddings or parties
you can technically get smaller than
average portion sizes but only in bulk
quantities for example in the us you can
get these
tiny party favor packs of m m's weigh in
just 0.75 ounces each or they have party
favor tins which contain 1.5 ounces of m
m's but both of these have to have a
minimum of 20 or more units now what
doesn't require a minimum order however
are the bulk bags in the u.s you can
order bulk bags of one pound two pounds
or five pounds now technically you could
order ten pounds of m ms but they just
send you two five pound bags which is a
bit disappointing so we just got one
five pounder
look at these m ms the uk website is a
similar situation our smallest portion
size is this 28 gram designer case but
the minimum order for these is 20.
unlike the us we only have one bulk bag
order and that's this one which is 1.5
kilograms that's around 3.3 pounds which
is a 34 decrease from the largest single
bag size in the us if you do order m ms
on the website you can customize them we
chose some custom colors and also i put
some custom text on the mlms in terms of
colors i went for this lovely blue and
white color scheme to match my stunning
m m's t-shirt
then i had some fun putting some text
options on there firstly i went for
harry hart joe we also had to wrap the
show so i put a food wars one on there
then because i had the mind of a child i
tried to put some swear words on the m
ms and it turns out they actually try
and censor you for example if you try
and put the word poop on an m m a
warning message will flash you up
telling you to get in touch with the
team but there is a workaround for
example for the word poop by replacing
the o's with zeros i was able to get
around the censorship and create poop m
ms the same goes for replacing the eye
with a one in penis and replacing the a
with a four in balls this is some
serious journalism taking place right
here now harry of course went with uh
customizing m ms with fun words and
stuff on it i just went for pictures you
can get custom images on an m m so what
i did
is i got hairy face
and joe face
m ms
here are all the ingredients in
chocolate m ms in the uk
and here is everything in a bag of
classic m ms in the us
look at all those comments a few things
to note here firstly the food colorings
used in the two countries are wildly
different in the uk some of our colors
are natural including the curcumin and
the carotenes whereas in the us all our
colors are artificial blue number one is
used in both the us and the uk but we
also have blue number two red 40 yellow
five and yellow six blue two is a less
common one it's also known as indigo
carmine the good news is it won't make
your kids hyperactive the more
interesting news is that blue two is
filtered rapidly through the kidneys and
consuming enough of it will turn your
pee blue
the practical use of this is so doctors
can highlight your urinary tract for
surgeries a less practical effect to use
is to freak out your friends hey yo
we're doing jokes in the script
apparently hey welcome to food wars
so anyway
turn your piss blue speaking of carmine
what about the carmine used in british m
ms standard carmine is a red food
colouring with the codenames red 4 or
e120 it's a natural food dye but what is
the natural source you ask it's
cochineal beetles
if you grind up cochineal beetles you're
left with a red powder which when mixed
with water and some chemicals can be
turned into a very stable dye obviously
we're going to now have to try and make
our own
[Laughter]
but you can see the red color coming off
of it already
i'm going to try and put some of this in
there mix it with some water and see
what happens
that has really worked wow
look how red that is that's incredible
as you can see just by chopping up some
beetles and mixing it with water we've
got this incredible kind of like blood
red food dye now while apparently
synthetic alternatives to carmine do
exist eminem's confirmed to us that the
carmen they use does in fact come from
beetles so technically every time you
eat a red m m in the uk you're eating
bugs
so do you want your kids hyperactive or
do you want them eating meals
not much of a choice is it
here are all the m ms products you'll
find in the uk that you won't find in
the us these are the m m products you'll
find in the us that you will not find in
the uk i'm so excited for this you leave
no idea oh my god i'm gonna try every
single one of these and i'm going to
right now all right first up peanut
butter m m's
love peanut butter m m's
fudge brownie
they're like the size of peanut m m's
but it's all chocolate inside i'm having
a hard time deciding the difference
between the fudge brownie and regular
chocolate pretzel m m's are my favorite
m ms these might be the best ones every
time m m comes out with like a new core
it's always like oh who cares pretzels
peanut butter crispy and they're always
amazing
caramel m m
more manageable rolo these are great
almond it's a new guy
dude's really good dark chocolate not a
big dark chocolate guy
a little more bitter than the regular
ones but they're still coated in candy
coffee nuts oh they're big oh and
they're kind of like the many shades of
coffee colored
oh i don't know about these the only
good coffee flavored thing is coffee
everything else is like dump out there
first miss mint dark chocolate it smells
a little smells a little bit like
toothpaste
ooh like yeah it's got a nice refreshing
this could replace brushing your teeth
in the morning eat a couple of these
white chocolate peanuts
yeah dude yeah
like the peanut ones but a little bit
sweeter and surprise this one is not in
the uk it is english toffee
no peanuts variety mega peanut is also
available here in the us and not in the
uk by the time of filming this i was not
able to get my hands on it one
understand it's like the peanuts like
really big now we don't have any major
exclusive flavors in the uk but we do
have some linguistic differences for
example while the us has caramel we have
salted caramel and while the u.s has
fudge brownie we have chocolate brownie
i want to see if you can actually taste
the salt in the salted caramel
you actually can now i am a sucker for
salted caramel but these are really good
we also have a bunch of seasonal m ms in
the u.s these include christmas options
such as sugar cookie m m what is up oh
yeah
those are good mint christmas
do m's go bad christmas was like two
months ago
yeah oh yeah bro
white chocolate pretzel snowballs i
think we had these for the christmas
episode i forget white chocolate
the pretzel gives it a little bit of
salt those are really good we also have
valentine's day options uh this is
a cupid mix and it looks like the only
difference is that the m has a heart
over it like there's a different
printing on it i mean it's fun to have
like themed candy but it's not like it's
not like a fun flavor and they spoke too
soon because we also have the
valentine's day black forest cake mix
no
there's also a dark chocolate cupid mix
we could not get at time of filming then
we have some products which aren't
classic m ms but use the m m's branding
the main event here is probably this
this is an m m's chocolate ball pool
party cake it says it serves 26. i'm
really struggling to see how you'd even
cut that into 26 pieces let alone have
slices which would then satisfy people
he's smiling but he looks like he's kind
of smiling through the pain at the
moment i feel you buddy happy birthday
to you
happy birthday to you oh god
there we go can you eat him or is he
plastic let's find out
i would assume edible
he's edible i'm not sure what he's made
of he does not taste good okay i'm
cutting myself a little piece
it's actually really not terrible if i
were eight years old again and someone
gave me a piece of this at a birthday
party i wouldn't complain following on
from the cake we've got a few more
exclusive eminem products in the uk
starting with these chocolate bars you
guys can get these in the us as well i
think we share the peanut and the milk
chocolate options but we have crispy as
an exclusive and cookie as an exclusive
they're basically just milk chocolate
bars with little pieces of crispy m m's
or cookies inside correct we do have the
chocolate bars here in the u.s as well
but one exclusive we have is this the
almond
m m's chocolate bar
next up we have this m m's spread with
crispy pieces now it's a chocolate and
hazelnut flavored spread with crispy
onions inside so it's basically like a
nutella and m m hybrid
well yeah i'm actually pretty impressed
by this it tastes basically the same as
nutella i don't know if they're actual m
ms or just kind of the crispy rice
pieces inside this but either way adds a
nice little crunch you know bit of
texture next up we have these m m's
double chocolate cookies now the double
chocolate in the name comes from the
fact that they are chocolate cookies and
then they also contain chocolate m ms
you know as far as the crunchy uk cookie
goes not too bad next up we've got two
easter egg options it's a sort of hollow
chocolate egg usually comes with a
couple of bags of sweets of your
choosing in this case m m's they're
given to kids around easter time to
celebrate the holiday now for m m's
these are available as either brownie or
crispy options i actually don't know if
americans do easter eggs joe is that i
think in the states easter eggs easter
candy easter chocolate easter baskets
easter bunny all that stuff is very
popular in america as well we can also
get a bunch of non-standard m m stuff
here in the us for instance we have m m
cookie ice cream sandwiches weird these
boxes are open that's so weird it says
four but there's only two in here i
don't know what happened you can get
them in mint
classic chocolate and
vanilla
there's also a chocolate one where the
ice cream is also chocolate that is not
available in my area see that
and they got the ice cream right there
we also have something called the
valentine's day
m m popcorn bucket one two three packets
of popcorn two boxes
one of the milk chocolate and one of the
peanuts also something that
i got
similar to this and i think it's an
exclusive it is milk chocolate popcorn
flavored m m's
it's weird like tastes like popcorn and
chocolate now preparation for this
episode i did something which no true
londoner should ever have to do which is
visit mlm's world in leicester square
now according to signs in the shop it's
the largest candy shop in europe and
also has the world's largest candy wall
i'm gonna be honest i absolutely hate
eminem's world and pretty much
everything it stands for it's kind of
like walking into the museum of
capitalism it's somehow an even bigger
tourist trap than like buckingham palace
i just don't understand why people would
come to london and make a beeline for
the m m store so i've not been to the m
m store in london but i've definitely
been to the one in new york city and
times square and i mean this as
sincerely as possible it's awesome i've
never been in before and i wasn't really
sure what to expect and i was
disappointed honestly i was expecting at
least some kind of innovative m m
flavors but it was just the same flavors
that you can normally buy in the stores
just kind of different colors and
different packaging the bulk of what
they had on offer in the store was
actually like eminem's merch like the uh
grotesque shirt that i'm wearing now
ironically for the record i'm just so
confused as to who would spend their own
money on this sort of stuff like why are
you loving eminem so much that you're
gonna pay a brand to let you advertise
for them harry
you are
you know what isn't ironic how much they
made on that shirt sale
this is what we do we like things we
wear it to show people look at the thing
i like it's capitalistic world and i'm a
cog in the machine fine i can't escape
so i might as well be comfortable and
that is my input on the matrix
don't unplug me i'm happy
all that said i did find one or two mlms
products which i couldn't find anywhere
else firstly there was one of the m m
chocolate bars with a flavor i couldn't
see anywhere else and that's hazelnut
then there are these two sachets of
powder firstly there is a cookie mix
apparently you add some butter and some
water to this and then you have some
ready to bake m m cookies and then
finally we have an m m's hot chocolate
powder
you know what this means we have to
summon the mug it's the return of
bouchie and we have guys oh it's got m
m's in it whoa
no that's fine it's better than the oreo
one the bar was admittedly really low
but given the option i would of course
make this with milk instead of hot water
and i think if you did that it would
actually be pretty good carrying on from
the early discussion about the m m
stores i do just want to quickly call
out m ms for having some really
questionable branding a big recurring
theme is that the mlms are really
sexualized in all of the marketing
materials there was that tv ad where the
m m was kind of in bed with that guy's
wife i feel like the green m m gets
sexualized quite a lot and also if you
go on the official mlm's website they
have some really questionable bios for
example if you go on the bio of the
brown eminem you'll see that she has a
turn on listed which is power her
appearance is described as sexy
sophisticated and her best attribute is
her big beautiful brain as part of my
eminem's world visit i did a scan which
told me which eminem i was and i got
yellow so let's take a look at his bio
so apparently my likes are pretty ladies
and fluffy things my appearance is plump
yellow and all smiles which yeah kind of
accurate although the bad news is i
might be an incel because my
shortcomings are that nice guys finish
last
the idea of giving these guys
personality to begin with is like jesus
christ can i just eat my candy in peace
in an unbelievable turn of events the
very day after we filmed most of this
episode eminem's announced that they
would be rebranding their m m's to be
more representative of the consumer
they've backtracked on a lot of the
sexualization of the m ms for example
the green eminem has swapped out her
high heels for sneakers and the brown
eminem has had the turn-ons removed from
her bio in the website this whole thing
prompted an explosion of memes on the
internet someone went to journalism
school to write some of these headlines
and i respect them for it i don't know
why anyone have you had an opinion on
this
for or against it you have to entirely
too much time on your hands it's also
worth pointing out that some have
suggested the m m's rebrand could be
suspiciously timed and that they might
be trying to draw attention away from an
ongoing class-action lawsuit mars the
owner of m m's along with several other
major chocolate producers including
hershey's nestle and more have been
accused of using cocoa from plantations
which use child slave laborers oh god
marge told bloomberg we do not comment
on any possible pending litigation oh
that's the fact that it wasn't a blanket
of course not what that like oh we can't
comment on it it's like that's a yes the
lawsuit is still ongoing so we'll have
to wait and see if any more details
emerge was the timing of the rebrand
coincidental or cynical we'll let you
guys decide i like how i just found out
about that after i ate all these m m's
well if i make everyone feel better i
have a huge headache from eating all
this junk food
in the u.s the recommended serving size
of m ms is 28 grams which is roughly one
ounce so when it comes to classic m m's
the u.s version has more calories
saturated fat carbs and sodium the uk m
m's actually contain more total fat as
well as more sugar sugar is the worst
nutritional offender as far as m m's are
concerned 28 grams of uk m ms contains
just over a third of your daily sugar
allowance what about the least
healthiest m m in the u.s well for us
it's a two-way tie between the peanut
butter and the white chocolate peanuts
both of these contain 150 calories per
28 grams as well as 8 grams of fat in
the uk our least healthy m m is peanuts
a 28 gram serving of uk peanut m ms
would contain 144 calories as well as a
slightly increased 7.28 grams of total
fat put my body on the line for content
i have no idea if that was fact checked
or not
but like everyone else i read something
on the internet it sounds true that's
good enough for me